this package charts a course for the
world to deliver on the promises made in
paris
this glasgow
climate pact drives action on adaptation
it emphasizes the need to act it sets a
clear way forward on the global goal on
adaptation and it urges developed
countries to at least double their
collective climate finance for
adaptation by 2025.
it operationalizes the santiago network
on loss and damage finally giving that
issue the focus and attention it
deserves
it commits to urgently scale up finance
which is the foundation for faster
action and confidence that we can go
further
and it sets out actions to empower and
engage all of society in driving forward
this transition
collectively
we have acknowledged that a gulf remains
between short-term targets and what is
needed to meet the paris temperature
goal
and so our pact brings parties back to
the table next year to improve their
commitments to drive up ambition across
this vital decade
and it emphasizes the urgent need to
accelerate our efforts to turn targets
into actions to keep 1.5 within reach
and that work must start now
we have also for the first time adopted
texts to scale up clean power and phase
down dirty coal
and after no less than six years of
discussions friends we have concluded on
those final parts of the paris agreement
rule book on article 6 on common time
frames and on transparency
and these put in place the rules and
systems to keep us accountable and
support increased ambition
their resolution will unleash the full
force of what was agreed in paris
this is real progress in keeping 1.5
degrees within reach
progress that we have made together
but the need for continual action and
implementation to match ambition must
continue throughout this decade
i think today
we can say with credibility
that we have kept 1.5 degrees within
reach
but
its pulse
is weak
and it will only survive if we keep our
promises
if we translate commitments
into rapid action
and if we deliver on the expectations
set out in this glasgow climate pact to
increase ambition to 2030 and beyond
and
if
we close the vast gap that remains as we
must
because as prime minister miami told us
at the start of this conference
for barbados and other small island
states she said
two degrees
is a death sentence
it is up to all of us
to sustain our load star of keeping 1.5
degrees within reach
to continue our efforts to get finance
flowing and boost adaptation
after the collective dedication which
has delivered the glasgow climate pact
our work here cannot be wasted
the drive towards 1.5 for a cleaner
healthier more prosperous and more
resilient world must continue and we
must continue that together
at the start of this summit
the world was asking
quite rightly
do the parties assembled here in glasgow
have the courage to rise to the scale of
the challenge
well my friends you have responded
we have
responded
history has been made here in glasgow
and what we now need to ensure that the
next chapter
charts the success of the commitments
that we have solemnly made together in
the glasgow climate pact thank you